yay all right we have
we have fixed our technical difficulties
so uh check us out tallyproject.org and
github.comtaliproject
and you'll find all of our work there so
like i said previous talk was awesome
we're doing it in real life at microsoft
it's all completely open source
so today uh i'm going to digress just a
little bit
a little bit and we're going to talk
about asynchronous javascript
at netflix i of course am
very unoriginal in my name matthew
podvasutsuki
and of course yes that is my twitter
handle
and yes also my github handle uh
so really what what it was was async
programming javascript but what really i
like this
to be is how i stopped to worrying about
asynchronous programming
and love to learn the observable so you
know i could go like this and ride a
bomb
but i'm not going to next um
anyways uh slides also started off with
a little bit of levity i thought i had a
problem so i thought to myself
you know i'll solve my problem with
promises and events
have now two problems i oops
so what this is not going to be it's not
going to be a
if you've seen my former boss eric meyer
he usually talks about monad's category
theory and so forth
uh there will be none of that although
if you're really interested
i mean a monad really is just a monoid
in the category
of endo functors i mean really what's
the problem what's the deal here it
should be
rather simple for you to understand that
yes
so here i am like i said i'm a principal
sde at microsoft
that small company and uh
that everything that i do at the company
is open source so whether it's the tally
project
or the reactive extensions which i'm
talking about
today you can find me here and
everywhere
pretty much using that same handle and
yes i do work for this
this small company called microsoft but
i think just because
i'm working with a lot of open source
that i add a little bit of metal to it
by adding um lots because that just kind
of rocks
anyways so uh you know we recently
announced this browser called edge as
well
but you know some people thought it was
the u2 guitarist but no
it was based upon me so i'm just
a little humble brag there
but the problem is i could i found that
i'm not as good of a
of a songwriter because
javascript has thoroughly corrupted my
mind so if i said you and me makes
2.0004 crap
yes thanks javascript
so i work on a project uh almost full
time called the reactive extensions and
this is a
language neutral approach to
asynchronous and event-based programming
across a number of languages and if you
go to that website if you have internet
con
internet connectivity uh you can go
there check us out
you'll have a lot of documentation and a
lot of
various cool things to check out so
if we go here to
reactivex.ios sure enough you can choose
your platform
but you can go down there and see all of
the the things that andre was talking
about in terms of these marble diagrams
and you can basically see how you can
get started with
with the with rx
so it's really kind of a cool project
and we've really made sure that it's
really cross-platform but what i'm
really saying is i'm an rx pusher i
like to say it belongs everywhere but so
let's bring it back to actually the main
topic here is netflix so
netflix is a company that streams movies
from and tv shows from any device
and what it accounts for is one-third of
all the us broadband traffic and that's
just as of a year ago could be more now
but they had some really really big
problems that they had to solve
in order to fix this because they had
some really basic
uh problems really basic problems
and they had them across different
languages but they thought differently
about events in asynchronous programming
so that they could create these very
rich
interactive user interfaces
so if anyone has the netflix app on your
phone
chances are you're running our software
everything about that application as
andre
uh so eloquently put everything about
these applications is asynchronous
whether it's
your app startup the player the the data
access the animations the view model
bindings
all of that is very very asynchronous
but it also leads to a number of
nightmares just because you're dealing
with asynchronous programming
you're dealing with possible memory
leaks with event handlers
leaking you have race conditions whether
callbacks
happen or events happen at a certain
time you have this thing called callback
hell which i'll get into
but really you have these complex state
machines where the state is just
sprinkled throughout
all of your code as well as the error
handling itself
is all is all just very disjointed and
it's really hard to find out where the
actual
logic for your application is versus
everything else
so if we go back a couple of years
they started with um with
i would say about four or five different
platforms and what was uh
bad about this is because each and every
language had its own real
way of of talking about asynchronous uh
stuff they had a back end
uh using java they didn't know how to to
really
scale that out you had the the user
interfaces very tightly coupled in terms
of
the the client and the server were very
very connected
there was no real clean abstraction
for how they do that so what they
decided to do
is they decided to to adopt rx
now we have a problem in today's
in today's uh in today's world and that
problem is that we are just
inundated with data uh whether it's your
phone whether
when you have uh you know when you have
your twitter app you have any number of
apps you have at least six or seven
different things whether it's your
accelerometer your gps etc everything's
firing at you none of it's really pool
based
so how do you manage it all without
having to stuff it down your shirt
is a really interesting problem
but the problem has always been is that
asynchronous programming is just plain
awful
uh you can i as you as you can see we're
managing all sorts of states and then
once we actually try to do an action
i it just immediately falls over
that's pretty much it so
we had a a very progressive president
back in the day and and he decided
in 1962 he was going to say we choose to
solve asynchronous programming and do
other things not because they're easy
but because they are hard now he later
changed this to actually going to the
moon
and the reason why that is is because he
actually thought going to the moon was
possible
not asynchronous of programming so it it
that wasn't solved in the 1960s and
apparently
a citation needed oh well
so callback hell really is a thing you
know many people say oh no
no no you've just uh uh you've just
you know designed your application wrong
well no that's not really true
what it is is you're dealing with these
various complex state machines whether
you're
uh there's a player error whether you've
got a ticket
and so it's really hard to kind of
follow where your code is going
in terms of what's the next step and
with retries and everything else it's
really really nasty stuff and most
people you know call it the temple of
doom or something like that but i
i equate it to a cow's head because it
just walks off the screen like that and
walks right back
and i don't know about you but usually
you're playing with fire when you're
dealing with uh with
uh callback hell and so anyways
uh and yes i do happen to jump out the
window sometimes so when dealing with
that
but dealing with events is just as awful
the idea of of having just a simple drag
and drop has
a lot of boilerplate code to it you know
whether the mouse is down whether the
mouse is
up uh what sort of state you have in
between there
you have to add the event listeners and
then you have to remove them
and you just end up with just so much
state
passed throughout the application so
like i said it's it gets very very
complicated very quickly because you're
trying to manage
all of these different moving pieces at
once and it never quite works out the
way you think it should
so everyone goes oh yes promises
promises will solve all of our problems
you know promises are coming in you know
es6 es25 whatever you want to call it
uh the idea that you could say player
the initialize then
authorize the movie else you've got to
log in air and play the movie or else
it's
unauthorized that's just peachy uh
the problem is is that we have several
several problems with this very approach
because promises lack a
fundamental thing that's required for
doing
anything io related and that is cancel
there is no such thing so if you are
doing something like an autocomplete
with a promise right
i'm continuing to type and this promise
is hanging out
here and it's going to eventually return
how do i tell it not to
well i can't not the way that promises
are currently designed
in es6 slash es25 2015
so that's a problem and in fact it
became so much of a problem in that they
they introduced this fetch api in uh for
uh the next version of of of the browser
so there and what it turned out to be is
yes
cancel became the number one issue
and as you can see here there are 182
comments on
how people are trying to cancel a
promise
so i guess that answer answers the the
question of how many engineers does it
take to cancel a promise
uh so as i said you know you can check
it out yourself
github whatwig issues27 i'm sure there's
more ideas and more things there
and like i said it's been an awkward
issue for a number of promises libraries
that they can't quite
figure out how to do uh cancellation
properly
and once again you have the the issue as
well
is the fact that there's no such thing
as finally either
in promises oops
so there's no way of of finally cleaning
up after
after you're done and disposing of your
resources
so as i said you've got a nice little uh
you've got a nice car
you've got a nice gas pedal you've got
some nice cup holders
but you forgot brakes it happens
so unsafe at any speed
so when people started to say well what
about stream processing why couldn't we
just use some of the ideas from
say node streams for example well
let's face it right now that if you used
node
way back when you'll realize that
streams are really terrible
i mean they the pause didn't data
started immediately whether you were
ready or not poor kid
uh and pause and resume were really
impossible to get right i mean there
were geniuses out there such as sub
stack and dominic tarr who did a lot of
stuff but fundamentally the core was
rotten
and broken and then they've then they
changed to streams 2
and streams 3 but still it's not quite a
perfect fit for doing a lot of this
event-based processing that we're trying
to talk about here
so instead we took a different approach
and went back to 1994
and we went to this book called design
patterns
i don't know how many people still have
it how many how many people were born
before then you know
whatever but we had a lot of patterns
here but what you saw as you saw a lot
of these different things are all
connected to one another
except these two which is kind of
strange we're like iterator and
observers should be
kind of connected and the reason why is
because we have the idea of a push-based
collection
and a pool based collection so with
es2015 we have the idea of
if first class iterators where we call
next
and then we can go through and get all
the values as they come
through and the same thing applies uh
the subject observer pattern as strictly
implemented
in in javascript it happens all over the
place with the dom
you know anytime you add an event
listener that's really just the subject
observer pattern
so anytime i move the mouse yay i get
values
pushed at me so it's a pull versus push
kind of collection
so let me ask you a question then what's
the difference between an array
and an event and they're both
collections
and that's the really the key part here
and what we can do is we can write the
majority of of netflix's
code with just a few flexible functions
so as as andre talked about before
with map the idea of transforming each
individual item
to filter items emitted by a collection
uh to kind of merging them all into a
single one
and then flat map which is basically
that map and merge all
into a single collection so now we can
actually take a look
and see inside of netflix how they would
sit get your top rated movies
well you would start with a given user
and you would look over their video list
and you would map with their video list
and you would go through
and filter where the rating is is
the top five and you would merge them
all or you could just go
call flat map and be done with it now
what if i told you
that same code that we showed here you
could create a drag event
you know it it's really kind of that
simple and the fact
is instead of filter we have taken till
so we have take until dom mouse move up
or just
flat map so let's take a look at this
again
flat map filter
flat map flat map take until that's it
you now suddenly are all
reactive extensions programmers done
and what you realize is that oh great
everything's a stream my mouse is a
stream
my phone's input is a stream
everything's a stream and it's kind of a
zen-like moment when you kind of realize
that
because now instead of these callbacks
that you had to deal with before with
the subject observer pattern we now have
a first-class object
now first-class object that we were
talking about are the things that we can
filter and reduce etc
but we can also inject in into methods
and we can return them from methods
which is great for testing and any
number of
of things now where does it fit in the
world
well with with uh with the world
we have synchronous and asynchronous
with multiple value and single values so
for
obviously for synchronous and single
value we have
object and then we have an array for
multiple values
then we have a promise which like i said
you can do then and
but here the observable you will see the
exact same code
applies from array to observable
no changes other than the fact that it
happens to be an observable source
so people keep asking well what is this
buzzword about reactive programming
because everyone sees reacts whatever
you know it's such an overloaded term
now and so people are saying well what
is react well
the dictionary just says readily
responds to a stimulus
okay not really all that useful is it
uh so basically active and ready to
respond to events
ah you know what's uh you know what just
go to this paper and just read that
instead bitly
bitly slash reactive paper i know people
are are are kind of averse to
reading papers like this and this is
their general reaction
but i i guarantee you it's it's well
worth your time
if you do that
now functional reactive programming is
something that people talk about quite
often
and they're like frp frp and i was like
well
we're not frp because frp is a very
specific term for continuous time
behaviors over time the idea of
basically having a continuous cycle
javascript you can't really do that it's
a single threaded environment you have
callbacks etc so it's really not
frp at all it's not just adding felt map
filter reduce onto events so just
call us whatever i mean call us
compositional event processing if you're
not into the whole
brevity thing you know uh
and and like i said between the push and
the pool world
there is no difference filter map for
each
filter map for each all of those are
exactly the same
so let's actually talk about the
creation what exactly
is an observable well let's actually
talk about that real quickly because
this is why it's very very interesting
so for example if we wanted to create
something like from event
we would have some sort of element and
events we would call the
uh we would have some sort of handler
which would call
next with our given value then we would
hook that up to add event listener with
our handler
and then afterwards we would create this
little teardown function
and that's really great when you're
dealing with a lot of events as you're
composing them together
and if you want to to unsubscribe
with take and tell or anything like that
then that automatically removes the
handler
you don't have to to do that yourself
so netflix search we could do uh
autocompletes basically with uh with the
same
kind of code where you can take the key
ups we can get the value
we can debounce it so maybe we're typing
too fast and we don't want to send all
of that to the server at once
we can get the latest term so uh when
we're dealing with asynchronous
programming there's the idea of you
getting out of order responses
with flatmap latest that's not possible
we canceled the previous uh previous
request
and then only the current request is
valid
so that's pretty cool and the fact that
then we can call for each and then bind
it directly to the ui
with our data so what rx is is just
three basic concept the observer and the
observable which we've kind of covered
in a little bit
we have the idea of on next on air and
on completed
where we can have an infinite value a
couple values and an error
a couple a couple values in an end but
you can't have overlapped values
and you can't have things that happen
after the fact
and so we have that map filter and
reduce that we talked about earlier but
how do we actually use it in something
usable you know so
what we could do is we could poll for
client updates so that's a really kind
of a cool problem to have
don't you think is that
what you can do is that you can
make sure that what you're doing is is
very responsive so here we're going to
listen for the document scrolling so as
as something is on your hardware
constrained device and you want to make
sure that you only keep in memory
what's on the screen nothing more
nothing less
so in order to do that we have to first
listen to the scroll event
and then we have to start debouncing so
allowing people to you know scroll up
scroll down
very nicely and then what we can do is
we can then
further divide that into whether it's
visible or not
and then we can combine this all
together with a kind of an interval so
so we're constantly listening and taking
that row data
until it's hidden and when it's hidden
it's gone
so this is kind of some netflix code
that they actually use today in terms of
how they
uh how they handle a lot of this complex
user interface design
and the player itself like i said you
could design it with callback hell which
is what they originally had
which you ended up with this cow head
but instead with
with observables we have a very very
simple approach to that
and that is uh we can initialize flat
map
play attempts uh then we can authorize
retry three times and take until cancel
something that we couldn't easily do
with that callback held version which is
that if someone hits that cancel button
it will actually stop the whole
transaction from going through
that's cool because now we have the the
ability to kind of
merge together all of these different
events into one
and they have also had another uh set of
problems is
how do they deal with uh with errors and
so forth
with uh websockets well we have an idea
of
where uh they uh netflix has created web
uh
websocket subject where they can hand it
multiple endpoints and it keeps failing
over until it actually gets something
but that's kind of cool too in the fact
that you can uh you can listen
and you can decide when to send data and
so forth
and yes you can do try catch finally so
for example
uh when person was asking about uh
handling errors well here we can say
dot catch and so for example if you're
in in a
uh in a constrained environment where uh
things such as as offline matters you
can get some default data and put it in
there
and then you can finally do some cleanup
and then you can process each item as it
comes through
now the role of schedulers is kind of
our secret sauce and what really
kind of of puts us apart and it really
is
is where do i run these values and how
so we have this idea of many different
ways about handling
handling schedulers in such a way that
we can schedule some work
and we can also cancel it at any time so
all of that cancellation that i've
talked about
goes all the way to the very core of
what we do
and it provides some testing benefits
for angular you could fit it into the
digest
cycle for any number of things you can
also
choose a very specific implementation
and of course you can do some
deterministic testing such as js conf bp
2015 happens at this particular times
and we can always determine always
that it happened then so there's no
callbacks there's nothing in terms of
when you're testing observables
it just works now schedulers do matter
so for example
if we are if we're taking something like
we want to draw something on a screen
well if we
take the default scheduler the problem
is going to be
is it's going to eat up our cpu i mean
it will if if
if my fan weren't going it would
probably levitate just because the fan
was going so hard
is because it's just drawing every
single time as
fast as it can through uh through the
fastest
available means on your on your platform
but instead what we could do is we can
swap that out and suddenly
we can say request animation frame
scheduler and now it looks
actually sane and guess what your your
computer is not going to levitate
anymore because
uh just because that it happens to
to eat up a lot of resources we have
back pressure as well that's not super
super important but it
but for a lot of people that are
concerned about how much traffic they
get
we have pause and resume capabilities
and async await
given the fact that it's coming to to
javascript
v next whatever that is the es7
es2016 whatever you want to call it the
idea of async and await is coming
in some form or fashion but you can
already do that today
with the spawn function uh inside of rx
where you can do the retry
catch and finally all of that and then
log the result
we have that today so you're living in
the future already
and then what we're working on uh now is
uh we're working on the the idea of of
taking observables and
moving it into uh into es7 directly so
the fact of
now you can get your mouse drags and
your mouse moves
and take until mouse ups all completely
native
to your browser if you want to learn how
to do this
we have a great tutorial out there
jayhusain.github.io
learnrx all of this is on our site
rxmarbles a great
site by andre is
also a great way to learn how each
individual operator works and if you
really want to see how something complex
is designed
there is uh there is a sweet js and it's
a
idea of a macro based language but all
of the
the bits and pieces of the editor itself
is all in
rx and that's handling all of the the
state all of your initial
uh uh settings and so forth
so i'll i'll leave you with this before
we dive into some demos but what i
really want you to remember
is push oh dear
why are you oh okay
are you not going to well let's see if
it plays
apparently uh apparently the uh the gods
are not smiling upon me today in terms
of
actual audio so i will go directly to
you come see me afterwards and we'll
play it together
it'll be great i i guarantee you uh so
if you go to our our website like i said
we have a lot of material here
uh we have our design guidelines we have
our recipes our unit tests
uh we have all of these ways people are
using it with react today
using instead of flux i think my
favorite one is thundercats.js
just because of the name is kind of cool
and you can do some really kind of cool
things you like interactions here
in using using rx and react together
you can also do autocomplete obviously
if you have great internet
but you can also do things like game
programming so for example all of this
thing where
mario is jumping and so forth and moving
about
all has to deal with keyboard events
gravity and all of these other things
that you can just kind of merge together
and like i said since it is such such a
thing with with game programming is the
fact that
you know you can play games to your
heart's content because what you're
dealing with is you're dealing with
timers you're dealing with
uh bounds checks you're dealing with uh
keyboard events
and so forth and so as as you can see we
we lost it hit that bounce check and so
forth
and like i said great for animation
great for for those
sorts of things uh and let's see
uh did i ah there we are
uh we can also play pac-man uh so if
you're so inclined to play pac-man
uh in in javascript uh yay
you can do it
we can also do a very complex user user
interfaces such as you know coordinating
all of our event handlers together we
can
paint on a canvas so i can start taking
different colors
all of these are in our samples today
you can take a look at them
they're all there and this is the like i
said the the request animation frame
scheduler
uh and as you can see my my machine is
not lifting off of its off of its
moorings here
uh now one other cool project is how do
i actually visualize
what i'm what i'm doing here so for
example if we had some
uh some code here where we we take and
we take from event and we do some
mapping
and subscribe to it what does it look
like yes we've got some output here
but down below physically tells us
exactly what
happened in terms of of creation
of events mapping and subscription of
each one and when it happened
really really kind of cool stuff uh
in addition to the work that andres did
with cycle there's also webrx there's a
great stuff and as well as cycle which
andre has so done so i will wrap things
up here with that
and so thank you very much
i think we could like get a tan in this
light at least
i could um i i have one question from
twitter
and i just love this question i don't
know how to even read it without
laughing
um the star color on your hat
gold or blue hashtag dress gate oh good
glory
so they are the yes the uh some are blue
some are gold and some are silver so
yeah problem solved
ever asked that question um i didn't see
anything else on twitter
uh so i thought it must have been boring
or something i don't know
or the hat was just so amazing that
everyone was so distracted they weren't
even listening
this is very very possible so i mean
like i said
it's funny because you know i've been
working on this particular project for
for five years now and what we're seeing
is is kind of mass adoption
through through github through slack
through
through netflix and even microsoft so if
you're using like microsoft online all
of that
uses uses rx so it's kind of interesting
just to see
over time how how kind of things have
just
radically changed and people are finally
accepting the idea
uh five years after the fact because we
presented this back at jscom 2010
2010 and went over most people's heads
pardon me questions
didn't see anyone oh there's a question
over there two
questions
raise your hands
i need your questions they were just
hiding or they were just like so in a or
like you know i'm so impressed by your
hat that just couldn't
i could have worn my robots cough hats i
don't know if that would have been less
distracting
um kind of a general question first of
all
uh does rx play well with angular or is
it
a lot more focused uh or works a lot
better with the react
um well that's a that's a good question
so uh
one one slide i kind of cut at the last
moment but it really does play well with
the libraries that you use so for
example we have rx.angular.js
which basically does a lot of the
bridging to and from
angular directly so for example if
you're if you want to do certain things
within the
digest cycle we have kind of helper
methods to do all that
uh react everyone is doing stuff with it
but there's
there are a lot of projects like rx
react and so forth
as well as rxember and you know rxjquery
all of those sorts of things so it
blends very very well you don't have to
throw out everything that you've ever
done
you can you continue to use it just the
way that's
you know kind of mixing it in and and
into your current project
one other thing um i didn't quite
understand regarding the promises
does does it somehow play in with it or
they completely separate concepts that
don't work together well they are they
are
they are separate concepts but no we we
do play very well with promises in the
fact that
things like the flat map operator that
we showed up there
uh merge and many others actually accept
promises and will convert them
automatically to observables for you
so just because you can you know
call jquery or or angular
and get back a promise you it binds
directly you don't have to do any uh
special
magic or voodoo yourself what's kind of
interesting
you you mentioned angular earlier uh
what they're doing
for for uh for for uh for all of their i
o going forward in angular 2 uh they
have
adopted observables as part of what
they're doing
uh so that you'll be able to use dot
subscribe and and all of the other
you know filters and maps and so forth
uh that's
that i showed you here okay thanks a lot
there was another question over there
over there
now we need to go all the way around
exactly just jump
like true people i just crawl over
people
but it doesn't matter right
oh yeah so i've been i've been playing
with it a bit
okay what's the best way so when you've
got an observable and a stream of
functions what's the best way to debug
it
uh debugging well i there are many ways
about doing that we actually have that
in our documentation
but debugging you can you can either put
breakpoints in
in each of your your function callbacks
for map filter and so on
but we also have this notion of do or
tap where it captures each individual
value
as it comes through so here it's this
here it's that and then you can do a lot
of
what i call caveman debugging where
you're just calling console.log
everywhere
but that's not really scalable in terms
of getting the right answer
in terms of where your your program
failed so we have this this notion of
long stack traces and the idea behind
that
is we eliminate all of the rx code and
all of the the the browser
code and only keep it down to your code
as to
keeping the stack from that so if you're
if it fails during a map or a filter or
something
i will immediately have that in the air
stack and
we won't report anything that rx did
okay so that's really kind of good for
for debugging purposes as well
cool thanks i think the caveman
debugging is going
in history now you know like people are
going yeah yeah exactly
can you like use this special technique
you know okay when debugging like that's
what we're rolling with right now
exactly caveman debugging let's let's go
old school like
yeah like that's very agile absolutely
uh all you have to do is just
uh do uh uh control replace and you know
get rid of all your console.logs
afterwards
oh my god okay one more question
yeah hello uh is these ideas
uh good to implement also in node.js on
server side you know handling requests
well absolutely uh in fact um
one of the the examples that we have we
have a couple of
examples using it on a tesla but we also
have it using uh working on nodes so for
example
uh you know at netflix they use rx in
node
we have a little stocked uh stock
example where we uh we
where we take a stock feed and start
doing analysis such as you know
grouping them by the stock
the stock number uh the stock ticker
rather
and then you can do analysis such as
whether
there have been price spikes in the past
hour or something like that based upon
our buffering so absolutely
uh it's something something that i'm
using also on the thali project as well
server side okay we can get
one more and there too okay
where's the mic okay we have two
questions
is everyone starving yeah what does
lunch is
is that a is that a question yeah
lunches
after we finish talking uh thanks for
the kittens
um i'm very curious about how you handle
um event streams when they come in i
mean um
you mentioned the callback hell and like
events in interrupting each other
but how do you keep track of events uh
well what we have is we have like i said
the end the internal scheduler which
basically
allows for uh fifo uh to happen first in
first out so
so basically you cannot have things that
kind of overlap you have
you have them all in a queue basically
and so as one comes in
the other one comes in we can't guaran
necessarily guarantee order
uh you know when certain events happen
unless you use the right operator
to do that but but like i said is is
yeah there is no chance for an overlap
since
javascript's a single threaded
environment you're not going to run into
that anyways
uh but uh but the idea
is is is that yeah it will just start
merging all of these together as as
the as they happen thanks
okay one more question or we'll just
keep sitting here and talking about
javascript because obviously no one is
hungry
and javascript is just that awesome
hi uh i just want to ask that how would
you compare
observables to csp and like go or
choreosync and clojure script
okay so uh so how does observables
compare to csp or communicating
sequential processes
well csp is a very very low level
way of dealing with io for example is
the fact that you have this channel
where you can start sending out values
on
the problem with with that approach
especially for asynchronous programming
is there is no
dedicated error handling uh technique
there is no
uh there are no ways of automatically
cleaning up resources and all of that so
it it's fine for certain aspects but in
terms of building really complex stuff
it falls down really quickly because csp
does is because it
it misses the the deterministic
finalization
and it misses the error handling uh
components but
if you're willing to do very low level
stuff of just emitting values
csp is fine
okay well that was really awesome qa and
i would assume that everyone is hungry
and if not
it's lunchtime anyway
we'll have i think an hour and a half
for lunch right now
so take it slowly outside and get your
food and be mindful of your
colleagues that are hungry as well
yep thank you matthew
you